si haría una gira el selector de la
estufa a 135 grados a la derecha cuando
las temperaturas quedará seleccionada
aquí tenemos dos cosas muy importantes
en primer lugar ella está girando el
selector 135 grados y hacia qué lado
está girando el selector no está girando
a la derecha entonces aquí está nuestro
selector este selector rojo apunta hacia
arriba como un tipo de reloj y vamos a
girar el selector hacia la derecha y
hasta dónde lo vamos a girar lo vamos a
girar 135 grados así que este es el
lector va a girar hasta alcanzar 135
grados cómo podemos saber dónde parar si
empezamos a girar nuestro selector
cuando alcanzará 135 grados bueno una
forma común sería usar un transportador
y podríamos medir 135 grados con un
transportador pero en este caso no lo
podemos hacer así porque no tenemos uno
así que vamos a usar otra información
que sabemos sobre ángulos para ver si
podemos resolver esto
conozco a un ángulo es un ángulo muy
común es el ángulo de 90 grados y un
ángulo de 90 grados si empezamos hacia
arriba como nuestro selector y giramos
90 grados vamos a terminar con un ángulo
como éste
es un ángulo al que le podemos poner un
cuadrado en medio es como un ángulo
cuadrado entonces este es un ángulo de
90 grados
así que regresando a nuestro selector si
empezamos en la parte superior y giramos
90 grados estamos aquí en la parte
superior y giramos 90 grados
vamos a terminar en la temperatura baja
90 grados pero no necesitamos girar 90
grados necesitamos girar 135 grados que
es más que 90 grados y aquí tenemos una
pista debemos avanzar más que la
temperatura baja no sabemos que tanto
más pero definitivamente vamos a pasar
la temperatura baja otro ángulo que
podría usar para ayudarme es el ángulo
llano de 180 grados si un ángulo de 180
grados empieza arriba como lo está
nuestra perilla en este momento como
nuestro selector vamos a avanzar todo
alrededor hasta tener un ángulo llano
como este así que una vez más regresamos
a nuestro selector si empezamos arriba y
giramos 180 grados
vamos a terminar apuntando hasta abajo
hasta la temperatura media esto sería a
180 grados entonces en dónde queda a 135
grados
bueno 135 grados queda entre 90 y 180 90
grados no fue suficiente y con 180
grados nos pasamos así que queremos algo
que esté en medio y cual temperatura
esté en medio de 90 y de 180 aquí
tenemos que en medio de ellas está la
temperatura media baja así que girar el
selector de nuestra estufa 135 grados a
la derecha para que seleccionemos la
temperatura media baja